Tesla the electric car maker is getting
dinged today the company downgraded by
Baird this follows a launch of its
much-hyped model x SUV I was out there
last week i got to drive it was a big
event but i was it it was great than
that it seems like what's the deal here
people aren't that impressed with it but
no i think everyone is incredibly
impressed with the product itself but
it's not all about the product right i
mean we know that Elon Musk and Tesla
are capable of building incredible
high-end luxury cars and this is no
exception maybe even more so because of
the Falcon wing doors that I County so
why so why did you guys let down so with
what that's one thing we know about Elon
Musk that he's able to deliver
incredible goods the other thing we know
about Elon Musk is that he's literally
always late he never is ever ever on
time and look this is like it was a
friend that was when was this when was
this model x supposed to come out
originally like 2013 right it was
delayed a few times yes push back yeah
but two times two years that's a big
delay and analysts like Adam Jonas at
Morgan Stanley and Baird as well our
concern that he just won't be able to
meet his targets for production either
so I'm sure that customers will line up
and buy as many as Tesla can make the
problem is Tesla probably can't make
that many for a little while it takes a
long time to ramp up production in the
car world he knows this as well and he's
got little signals little warnings
that's right and what's up with the
Tesla why okay so yesterday right he
tweeted the Tesla Model y and then
instantly deleted that tweet I'm not
sure if that was a reference to the
model 3 or if there's going to be a
lower price model x because one of the
other concerns that Morgan Stanley has
about the model X's that's just so
expensive I mean you're not getting into
this SUV for less than 120 130 thousand
dollars and that's before you put any
options on it anyone's ever built a car
especially Tesla knows that options end
up costing a lot so yeah maybe he's
going to come out with a lower price
version of this you don't need 691
horsepower do you well you might I mean
I think the American like it but you're
right the average American driver
doesn't need the amount of power any
matter performance that's in these cars
mean these are top-of-the-line luxury
products it would be easy to come out
with something that was a little bit a
little bit lower priced maybe lower
price is harder than lower performance
last week when they availed the model
like to me they did note that they
didn't have yet or they weren't going to
unveil you at the base price or the
model like so that might that
uncertainty might ask it's gonna be high
I'll give you an awesome BF a really
high